Pamela Birch Ford to Florida State
Conference of NAACP branches waves in
opposition Anita dick
is an opponent
waves in opposition
Holden hiscock is also an opponent waves
in opposition
uh Jimmy only Jimmy
I have nothing to say about that I just
found it really really funny and I was I
was identifying as my eight-year-old
self when I heard that and I giggled
quite a lot and I always loved when
there were moments of levity in politics
it's not the legislator's fault he's
just reading the names in front of him
the Seymour butts we got Seymour butts
here for commentary on the bill that's
great that's great I really like that
and everyone's so angry all the time in
politics it was killed this person and
not this Terror think of the children
and when you get a Holden macaque or
whatever the whatever the name was
that's really that's really great